eh ben je cherchais tient avec eric
non mais je les adore ses vrais gens me
connaissent et très gentil et pour trait
noir et je voulais vous l'adorez voici
on se connait même est ce que ça vous
ferait plaisir qu'on fasse un petit coin
congo haïti un petit duo de danse mais
eric et vous là je fais pas mon ciné
sérieux gilles brochard
rajhi de se laisser aller là alors il va
t'amuser mathieu vous lancer en or c'est
le premier coup bas soirée éric et
mathieu ou
ya quoi comme la musique attention c'est
parti on va mettre plusieurs musiques
sont tous les coups
échanges
[Musique]
alors
ça pèse
la deux
[Musique]
l'âge de mon fils
ces matelas maple leaf l'appareil c'est
bon ça fait du bien très mal à l'aise
avec eric on arrive de lci